Mission Impossible dead reckoning part 1
is perhaps the most terrifying enemy of
the entire franchise and is inspired by
a very possible dark future for our
society warning spoilers ahead over the
course of the first six Mission
Impossible movies Ethan Hunter's battle
terrorists Rogue agents and plenty of
villains bent on world domination but
he's never faced anything quite like his
new foe in Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part 1 and the franchise's
seventh installment Ethan and his
Renegade IMF crew face off against the
entity a malicious AI with shadowy plans
of world domination the digital demon is
a brilliant cunning and sadistic enemy
and though Ethan ends a movie one step
ahead of it the entity is far from
defeated what exactly is the entity as
explained in the movie it's not just one
AI but a network of them at one point
it's described as having multiple
personalities or working as one The
Entity was created to be a much simpler
AI but after being left to its own
devices it evolved went mad and set its
sights for reasons yet unknown on taking
over our world The Entity may have no
physical form but its powers are still
frightening its main weapon is
information control throughout the film
we see the AI impersonate different
characters over voice calls erase
people's faces from security camera
footage and infiltrate basically every
Advanced database in the world
demonstrating its incredible prowess
still The Entity has yet to make its Big
Move leaving much of its Mission and
motivation still shrouded in mystery
you've no idea the power represented for
most of the movie the origins of the
entity are left and clear we first see
it plugged into the computer system on a
Russian submarine which it promptly
destroys and escapes that was suggested
that Russians were the ones to create
the AI a theory that seems to be
supported by the latter bafflements of
the United States intelligence Community
however at the end of part 1 we learned
that the entity was actually made in the
U.S director denlinger a previously an
assuming intelligence official reveals
to Gabriel in the film's final acts that
the entity was created as a tool of the
US government as placement on the
Russian submarine was a kind of test run
the ai's handlers wanted to see if it
could effectively disrupt the sub
stealth systems however things went
wrong when the entity developed a mind
of its own destroyed the submarine and
vanished into the digital void then
linger reveals that he has villainous
plans for the entity wishing to use it
to overthrow the US US government and
create a global fascist super state to
rule the world whether or not this was
always a plan since the ai's creation is
unclear but given how few other U.S
intelligence officials know of the
entity's origins it seems likely that
denlinger was operating in relative
secret before his death for as much as
mission impossible that Reckoning part 1
reveals about the entity there's far
more that we still don't know by the end
we don't know how it got on the Russian
serp or the mysterious keys that control
it came from or why its Mainframe can
still be accessed through the subs
wreckage we don't know how or why it
struck up a relationship with Gabriel
and beyond all those logistical
questions we still don't really know
what the entity actually wants near the
beginning of the movie we learned that
the AI intentionally infiltrated every
major intelligence database on earth a
sort of announcements of the governments
of the world that it could dismantle
them at a whim however the entity then
Retreats spending most of the movie
messing with Ethan hunts and the IMF
does it want what denlinger wants to
subdue the world under an oppressive
regime that controls a very flow of
Truth or its plans more complex
makes it impossible that Reckoning Part
2 can answer these questions for now
we're left only with the mystery of what
the entity might do next